-Our first guest tonight
is an Oscar-, Emmy-,
and Tony-nominated actress
you know from "Up in the Air,"
the "Pitch Perfect" movies,
and HBO Max's "Love Life."
She stars in the film
"Alice, Darling,"
which opens exclusively
in AMC theaters nationwide
on January 20th.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Anna Kendrick,
everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome!
-Thanks for having me back.
-I'm so happy to have you back.
I want to ask about the movie
and a lot of other things,
but I especially want to ask,
before we get started --
you just did Sean Evans' show,
"Hot Ones."
-Yesterday.
-Yesterday?
-Yes.
-So, you're still
in the recovery period.
-I might still be on Neptune.
-Yeah.
-I might watch this back
and be like, "That happened?
I went on the show?"
-So, I did it, as well.
I think this is the best photo
of how I was feeling
when I did it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Was it -- how remarkable
did you find the experience?
-Yeah, life altering
is what it was.
Yeah, and I know that part of
the fun of watching the show
is sort of watching people
in distress.
And I will say,
I loved your episode.
-Thank you.
-Because you are suffering
so much.
-I'm so --
[ Laughter ]
-You are really
going through it.
-So upset the whole time.
-Yes.
And I think that I got mine
is --
like, yeah,
karma's a bitch, Anna.
Because I suffered so much.
-It's sort of
a remarkable construction,
because I did find
I was answering questions
probably in a way
that I would not have.
-Yes!
I think I was like using words
that I don't normally use.
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"Can I speak French?
Like, if I just tried,
would it work?"
[ Laughter ]
-Well, there you go.
I'm very excited to see that.
I'm very excited about the fact
that you just finished
directing your first film.
-Yeah.
-How did you like
the experience?
-Thank you, thank you,
thank you!
It really, like -- it kind of
came out of nowhere.
And I had the time of my life
doing it.
It was so much fun.
I loved it so much.
It was also, like,
the first time
that I've dealt with the budget
in a real way.
I kind of didn't know
that the -- when --
even when you're the director,
it's kind of like weird
used-car-lot rules
where no one will tell you,
like, a hard number.
-Uh-huh.
-So, I started to, like,
read facial expressions.
Like, when I would ask for
something, it would be like,
"Ooh, was that like a wince that
means $200 or like 5 grand?
What are we talking about here?"
And like --
sometimes I would be like,
"If I'd known that 'that'
meant 10 grand,
I wouldn't have asked for it!"
Like, cancel it, cancel it.
It's fine."
-Sometimes -- I remember once
there was something
where we were like,
"We would love to get a possum."
And they were like,
"Please get a raccoon."
[ Laughter ]
And that's how we found out,
like, possums,
you gotta
pay through the nose for.
But a raccoon --
-Really?
-Yeah.
Raccoon, you just put, like,
a garbage can out,
and they all just show up.
-They'll just do --
-They'll just do it, yeah.
-They're easy,
but possums are like divas.
They're like,
"I'm not getting out of bed
for less than 20 grand."
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"No, thank you."
-Wow.
-So that, I know what you mean.
Like, it's very --
Now, this is a true story.
Were you aware of the story
before you read the script
about it?
-Yeah, I sort of knew the story.
So the story is --
it's, yeah,
based on this crazy thing
that happened in the 1970s.
A woman
went on "The Dating Game,"
that game show
"The Dating Game."
And the person
she ended up picking
turned out to be
a serial killer.
[ Audience groans ]
Very cool.
[ Laughter ]
So, it's just this, like, yeah,
completely insane story,
and it's, like, kind of -- like,
it so captures your imagination
because it's like,
"Who am I on a date with?"
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Like, it could kind of be
anybody.
-Have you ever in your life
had a moment where you were
dating someone where you
thought, "This is a red flag"?
-When I was like 21
or something,
I went on a date with a guy.
We'd met at a party,
and we talked on the phone
a little bit.
And I went on a first date
with this guy.
And at the end of the date,
he -- he, like, seemed very shy,
and then he handed me
a piece of paper,
and it was a poem about me.
-Okay.
-Which is a big move
for a first date.
-Yeah.
-A really intense move.
And it -- like, on the one hand,
I was like,
"Maybe that's sweet."
But he'd done that thing
that you do, like,
if you're doing, like,
an elementary school project
about pirates or something
where he, like,
burned the edges of the paper.
[ Laughter ]
To make it look, like,
old timey.
[ Laughter ]
And that should've been
a red flag.
-Yeah.
So, was he saying, like,
"I wrote this about you
in a past life"?
-Yeah, maybe.
Yeah, we've been together
through the ages or something.
I did spend the next like three
months breaking up with him.
-Yeah.
-Like, I didn't just, like,
ghost him.
And I probably should have.
Sometimes people
need to get ghosted.
-Yeah.
-'Cause I was just, like,
trying to break it slowly to him
for, like, a really long time
that I -- no, thank you.
-You should have given him
one of those burned edges, like,
"I found the treasure map."
-"My past self
also rejected you."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I have heard that you
did not watch old episodes
of "The Dating Game" growing up.
Like, I think sometimes
I watched them on TV.
But you have a favorite
dating show
that I think is my favorite,
as well.
-Yeah. So, I'm obsessed
with "Love is Blind."
-"Love is Blind" is a special --
[ Cheers ]
-It's all I want to talk about.
Like, I don't want to keep
doing this interview.
Whoever just whoo'd,
I want to talk to you
about "Love is Blind."
[ Laughter ]
That's, like, all --
-Now, I have something to admit.
I only watched the first season.
Was the second season
as exceptional?
-This second season
was wonderful.
This last season, season three,
is really something, Seth.
-Okay.
-You really got to get on it.
-I don't know why we didn't
get back on the horse.
This sounds like
a real solid review.
-I'm, like, jealous of you
that you get to experience
season two and three.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm very excited for that.
I have so much more to ask you.
We'll be right back with more
from Anna Kendrick, everyone.